DOSSIER WILL BE INVESTIGATED
FINALLY.
THAT'S AT TONIGHT OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
TONIGHT WE START WITH
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA IGNORING
A MAJOR WARNING IN MARCH 2014
THAT RUSSIA WOULD TRY TO
INTERFERE IN THE ELECTIONS.
WHAT DID OBAMA DO IN 2016, 2015,
2014?
DID HE EVEN TRIED TO STOP IT?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
JUST WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
LISTEN TO WHAT THEN-PRESIDENT
OBAMA SAID.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN IN MY
LIFETIME OR IN MODERN POLITICAL
HISTORY ANY PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE TRYING TO DISCREDIT
THE ELECTIONS AND THE ELECTIONS
PROCESS BEFORE VOTES HAVE EVEN
TAKEN PLACE.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED.
IT HAPPENS TO BE BASED ON NO
FACTS.
THERE IS NO SERIOUS PERSON OUT
THERE THAT WOULD SUGGEST SOMEHOW
THAT YOU COULD EVEN RIG
AMERICA'S ELECTIONS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THAT
HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST, OR
THAT INCIDENCES AND THAT WILL
HAPPEN THIS TIME.
I'D ADVISE MR. TRUMP TO STOP
WHINING AND GO TRY TO MAKE HIS
CASE TO GET VOTES.
>> Sean: NO SERIOUS PERSON,
REALLY BARACK OBAMA?
HE OWES YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, TONIGHT AN EXPLANATION.
WHY DIDN'T HE KNOW?
HOW DID HE NOT KNOW WHAT HE WAS
WARNED IN 2014?
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A DERELICTION
OF DUTY.
A SIGN FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA TO
START TALKING MAY BE UNDER OATH.
NOW THAT YOU HAVE THE IMPORTANT
BACKGROUND INFORMATION, IT MAKES
SENSE WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
FIRING BACK AGAINST THIS
COMPLETELY BIASED NEWS MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT HAVE
WANTED TO DESTROY HIM FROM DAY
ONE OVER THIS DONATE RUSSIA
COLLUSION CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THE FACTS DO NOT MATTER FOR THE
LEFT.
THEY'VE CONVINCED THEMSELVES BY
REPEATING THEIR TALKING POINTS
AND THEIR ECHO CHAMBER THAT
SOMEHOW IN SOME WAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS, EVEN THOUGH AS WE
HAVE REPEATEDLY POINTED OUT,
ALONG OVER A YEAR, TO THIS DAY,
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THE ONLY CONCRETE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA WE HAVE IS
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER THAT'S
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES,
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT LIES, AND
PROPAGANDA AND SALACIOUS DETAILS
THAT WOULD NEVER BE VERIFIED.
SHE USED THAT AND TRY TO
INFLUENCE AN ELECTION WITH IT.
JUST LIKE HE ALWAYS DOES,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FIGHTING BACK
AND IS FIGHTING BACK ON TWITTER
TO REACT TO MUELLER'S INDICTMENT
FOR THE 2016 ELECTION MEDDLING.
THE PRESIDENT WRITES, "HOW FUNNY
THAT THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA DOESN'T
WANT TO SAY THE RUSSIAN GROUP
WAS FORMED IN 2014, LONG BEFORE
MY RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
MAYBE THEY KNEW I WAS GOING TO
RUN EVEN THOUGH I DID NOT KNOW.
ROBERT MUELLER'S INDICTMENT
CLEARLY LAYS OUT THAT THIS
RUSSIA ATTEMPT INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION THAT STARTED IN 2014,
UNDER OBAMA'S WATCH.
HE WAS WARNED.
HE DID NOTHING TO STOP IT.
BY THE WAY, GO BACK TO 2012
DURING A PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
BARACK OBAMA MOCKING MITT ROMNEY
FOR SAYING RUSSIA STILL POSE A
VERY SERIOUS FOREIGN POLICY
THREAT.
MITT ROMNEY WAS RIGHT.
OBAMA WAS WRONG.
THE MEDIA IGNORED ALL KEY FACTS
IN AT THE MUELLER INDICTMENT.
YOU CORRUPT PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
NEED TO LISTEN CLOSELY, VERY
CLOSELY TO WHAT THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BROUGHT
ROSENSTEIN SAID WHILE ANNOUNCING
THE CHARGES ON FRIDAY.
PAY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION.
YOU MAY ACTUALLY LEARN SOMETHING
YOU MAY ACTUALLY LEARN SOMETHIN
SOMETHING.
>> THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THIS INDICTMENT THAT ANY
AMERICAN WAS ANNOYING
PARTICIPANT IN THIS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THERE IS NO ALLEGATION OF
INDICTMENT THAT THE CHARGED
CONTENT ALTERED THE OUTCOME OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
AFTER THE ELECTION, THE
DEFENDANT ALLEGEDLY STAGED TO
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY STAGING
RALLIES TO PROTEST HIS ELECTION.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE DEFENDANTS
ORGANIZED ONE RALLY TO SUPPORT
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT AND ANOTHER
RALLY TO IMPOSE HIM BOTH IN
NEW YORK ON THE SAME DAY.
>> Sean: DID I JUST HEAR IT?
NO AMERICANS WERE WITTINGLY
INVOLVED IN THIS RUSSIAN EFFORT.
THIS WAS USED TO SOAK POLITICAL
DISCORD.
AFTER THE ELECTION, THESE
RUSSIAN CYBER TROLLS WERE TRYING
TO UNDERMINE THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT, DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WERE ORGANIZING DUELING
TRUMP RALLIES IN NEW YORK CITY
IN AN EMPTY TRUMP RALLY IN
CHARLOTTE, NORTH CAROLINA.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON WHAT IS
ACTUALLY IN THE SMALLER
INDICTMENT, WHAT BROUGHT
ROSENSTEIN SAID, THAT
COME CORRUPT MEDIA OF YOURS IS
TRYING TO USE IT TO FURTHER
THEIR FAKE NEWS, RUSSIAN
CONSPIRACY NARRATIVE.
TAKE A LOOK.
WE HAVE THE PROOF APPEARED TO
SPEAK OF THE GOAL HERE WAS
SIMPLE.
DAMAGE HILLARY CLINTON AND ELECT
DONALD TRUMP.
THESE RUSSIANS ALLEGEDLY WENT TO
GREAT LENGTHS.
>> HE'S FOUND THIS INCREDIBLE
NETWORK OF MEDDLING.
HE HAS A STRONGER BASIS ON WHICH
TO GO ON COLLUSION, THE EMAILS.
AND THE ISSUE OF THE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON HERE IS
ESTABLISHING AN ONGOING CRIME
AND HOW IT WILL BE CONSPIRACY TO
OBSTRUCT OR COLLUDE.
>> THERE MAY WELL BE INFORMATION
AND A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT THERE
WAS NOT ONLY UNWITTING BUT
WITTING ASSISTANCE FROM THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
CONTINUED TO ADVOCATE
RESPONSIBILITY HERE ABOUT
LEADING THE COUNTRY IN RESPONSE
TO ATTACK ON THE MOST CORE
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF OUR
DEMOCRACY, ARE FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
>> Sean: HE IS THE DUMBEST
ATTORNEY ON TV.
THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA ALSO
MISSED KEY PIECES OF INFORMATION
THAT WAS NOT IN THE MUELLER
INDICTMENT.
IT HAS NOTHING ABOUT TRUMP
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
WE SHALL HAVE ZERO EVIDENCE.
I'M WAITING.
IT SAYS NOTHING ABOUT THEM
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
IT SAYS NOTHING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP JR. COLLUDING WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
IT SAYS NOTHING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE.
LIBERAL MEDIA, ARE YOU PAYING
ATTENTION?
DO YOU EVEN CARE ABOUT THE
TRUTH?
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN SAYING
THAT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIANS.
NO COLLUSION.
BOTTOM LINE, THEY ALL SAY THERE
IS NO COLLUSION.
AND THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
COLLUSION.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY, THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO COLLUSION.
THAT IS BEEN PROVEN.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
COLLUSION.
I DIDN'T MAKE A PHONE CALL TO
RUSSIA.
I HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
WHAT HAS BEEN SHOWN IS NO
COLLUSION.
NO COLLUSION.
THERE'S BEEN ABSOLUTELY NO
COLLUSION.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT ALSO
TWEETED THIS WEEKEND, "I NEVER
SAID A BRUSH I DID NOT MEDDLE IN
THE ELECTION.
I SAID IT MAY BE RUSSIA OR CHINA
OR ANOTHER COUNTRY, OR IT MAY BE
A 400-POUND GENIUS SITTING IN
HIS BED AND PLAYING WITH HIS
COMPUTER.
THE RUSSIAN HOAX WAS AT THE
TRUMP CAMPING COLLUDED WITH
HE ADDED "IF THE GOAL OF RUSSIA
WAS TO CREATE CHAOS WITHIN THE
U.S., THEN WITH ALL THE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS,
INVESTIGATIONS, AND PARTY
HATRED, THEY HAVE SUCCEEDED
BEYOND THEIR WILDEST DREAMS.
THEY ARE LAUGHING THEIR BUTTS
OFF IN MOSCOW.
GET SMART AMERICA."
FOR OVER A YEAR, RUSSIA HAS BEEN
LAUGHING AT THOSE.
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA HAVE
BEEN PLAYING RIGHT INTO PUTIN'S
HANDS BY CREATING CHAOS AND
FRANKLY, IT'S WORKING BETTER
THAN WHAT RUSSIA COULD HAVE EVER
DREAMED OF.
THAT IS WHAT THIS RUSSIAN EFFORT
WAS ALL ABOUT.
CAUSING CHAOS, POLITICAL UNREST
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER" BYRON
YORK WILL JOIN US LATER TONIGHT.
HE IS OUT WITH A GREAT ARTICLE,
WHICH IS ENTITLED "A NONALARMIST
READING OF THE MUELLER RUSSIA
INDICTMENT."
THEY MAKE SOME KEY POINTS,
NAMELY THAT RUSSIAN STARTED ALL
OF THIS IN 2014.
DONALD TRUMP WASN'T RUNNING.
THE FOCUS WAS ON DAMAGING
HILLARY CLINTON.
EVERYONE THOUGHT SHE WAS GOING
TO WIN.
ALL OF YOU IN THE MEDIA WERE
LAUGHING AT THE IDEA OF
DONALD TRUMP RUNNING.
BYRON YORK ALSO CITES, FIGURES
FROM THE CENTRAL INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, THAT IN KEY
BATTLEGROUND STATES OF
WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN AND
PENNSYLVANIA, THE RUSSIANS ONLY
SPENT $3,000 ON FACEBOOK ADS.
THE INDICTMENT IS VERY VAGUE
ABOUT HOW MUCH THESE RUSSIAN
TROLL SPENT ON SOCIAL MEDIA AS.
IT ONLY SAYS THEY SPENT
"THOUSANDS EVERY MONTH."
THAT IS SMALL WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE COMBINED $2.4 MILLION THAT
THE CLINTON AND TRUMP CAMPAIGN
SPENT DURING THE ELECTION.
MOSTLY CLINTON.
IT'S NOT THAT MUCH MONEY.
TONIGHT, A FACEBOOK EXECUTIVE IS
SOUNDING OFF ABOUT THE BRUSH
INVESTIGATION.
HIS RATE IS ROB GOLDMAN.
HE'S A VICE PRESIDENT OF
ADVERTISING ON FACEBOOK.
HE SAID, "THE MAJORITY OF THE
RUSSIAN ADD SPENT HAPPENED AFTER
THE ELECTION.
WE SHARE THAT FACT, BUT VERY FEW
OUTLETS HAVE COVERED IT BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T ALIGN WITH THE MAIN
MEDIA NARRATIVE OF TRUMP AND THE
ELECTION.
THE RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
MISINFORMATION EFFORT IS TO
DIVIDE AMERICA BY USING HER
INSTITUTIONS LIKE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, SOCIAL MEDIA AGAINST US.
IT INSTILLS FEAR AND HATRED
AMONGST AMERICANS.
IT IS WORKING INCREDIBLY WELL.
WE ARE QUITE DIVIDED AS A NATION
WE ARE QUITE DIVIDED AS A NATIO
NATION.
EVEN FACEBOOK IS THROWING COLD
WATER ON THE MEDIA'S FAKE NEWS
NARRATIVE ABOUT MOLARS
INDICTMENT.
LET'S GET BACK TO OBAMA'S
FAILURE TO STOP THIS
INTERFERENCE.
CONGRESS MEANT DEVIN NUNES IN
2014 RAISE A RED FLAG THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN NEEDED TO BE
WATCHED CLOSELY.
OBAMA DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE.
TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
HE'S LECTURING TRUMP, "STOP
WHINING, IT COULD NEVER HAPPEN
HERE."
OBAMA DIDN'T DO MORE TO COMBAT
RUSSIA.
HE THOUGHT HILLARY WAS A SHOE
IN.
WHY INTERRUPT THIS?
WAS EVEN MORE DISTURBING IS THAT
THERE WERE EVEN EARLIER WARNING
SIGNS FROM RUSSIA.
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU ON THIS
PROGRAM HOW VLADIMIR PUTIN HAD
RUSSIAN OPERATIVES INSIDE
AMERICA RIGHT HERE ON OUR SOIL
AND HOW THEY WERE INVOLVED IN A
SOPHISTICATED PLOT THAT STARTED
IN 2009.
IT HAD A MAIN OBJECTIVE TO GET A
FOOTHOLD IN AMERICAS URANIUM
MARKET.
WE ACTUALLY HAD AN FBI INFORMANT
AND NOW KNOW HIS NAME, DOUGLAS
CAMPBELL.
WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT
THIS GUY.
THIS GUY HAS TESTIFIED FOR THREE
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES AND
LITERALLY WAS UNCOVERING AT THE
TIME IN 2009 AND 2010 THAT PUTIN
AND HIS OPERATIVES WERE INVOLVED
IN BRIBERY AND KICKBACKS AND
MONEY LAUNDERING AND
WHILE CORRUPT URANIUM ONE DEAL
WAS ALL BEING APPROVED 18 MONTHS
LATER.
HE COULDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY IT
DIDN'T TAKE HIS INTELLIGENCE.
THAT GAVE RUSSIA A HOSTEL FOR AN
ACTOR, CONTROLLING 20% OF
AMERICA'S URANIUM, WHO WOULD BE
STUPID TO DO THIS?
APPARENTLY OBAMA AND
HILLARY CLINTON AND ERIC HOLDER.
AT THE TIME, THE FBI DIRECTOR
ROBERT MUELLER.
MUELLER, WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS?
AMERICA ALREADY DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH URANIUM FOR NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
WHY WOULD WE GIVE 20% TO A
HOSTILE NATION, RUSSIA, AND A
HOSTILE ACTOR, PUTIN.
IT NEVER MADE SENSE AND DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
HERE WE ARE YEARS LATER IN THE
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS ARE SHOCKED.
THEY ARE FLABBERGASTED THAT
RUSSIA WOULD EVER EVEN DARE TO
TRY TO INFLUENCE OUR ELECTION,
EVEN THOUGH AS I JUST EXPLAINED,
THEY WERE EASILY ABLE TO BE
INVOLVED IN BRIBERY, EXTORTION,
KICKBACKS, WONDERING MONEY
LAUNDERING AND SECURE 20% OF
AMERICA'S URANIUM.
WHY WOULD THEY START?
THEY ALREADY KNEW WE WERE BEING
STUPID.
WHAT IS OBAMA TRYING TO DO TO
ISRAEL?
INFLUENCING ELECTIONS IS WRONG?
REMEMBER THE CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT BACK IN
2014, AN ISRAELI POLITICAL GROUP
USED 300,000 TAXPAYER DOLLARS,
THE OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT, TO
CREATE A POLITICAL APPARATUS TO
TRY AND DEFEAT OUR CLOSEST ALLY
IN THE MIDDLE EAST, THE ISRAELI
PRIME MINISTER.
IT DOESN'T STOP THERE.
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
INFLUENCING ELECTIONS.
THAT DATES BACK TO PLACES LIKE
ITALY, IRAN, GUATEMALA, CHILE,
NICARAGUA, AND THOSE ARE JUST A
FEW EXAMPLES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR TOLD LAURA INGRAHAM
ABOUT THE U.S. AND HOW WE
INTERFERE IN FOR ELECTIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HAVE WE EVER TRIED TO MEDDLE
IN OTHER COUNTRIES ELECTIONS?
>> OH, PROBABLY.
IT WAS FOR THE GOOD OF THE
SYSTEM IN ORDER TWO     TO AVOID
COMMUNIST TAKING OVER.
IN EUROPE, THE GREEKS AND
ITALIANS --
>> WE DON'T DO THAT NOW?
>> WELL...
ONLY FOR A VERY GOOD REASON.
>> CAN YOU DO THAT AGAIN CUTS TO
SPEAK ONLY FOR A VERY GOOD
BECAUSE.
>> Sean: LET ME BE CLEAR.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY AMERICA
SHOULD NOT BE DOING THIS.
I DO BELIEVE WE OUGHT TO BE
DOING THIS ON A BIT REGULAR
BASIS.
I BELIEVE INTELLIGENCE AND
COVERT OPERATIONS, PLAUSIBLE
DENIABILITY.
I BELIEVE IN ALL.
THANK GOD WE HAVE GOOD PEOPLE,
CIA, INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
MILITARY THAT ARE DOING THIS
EVERY DAY.
IT'S BEYOND NAIVE TO THINK THAT
THIS WOULDN'T HAPPEN TO US,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN RUSSIA SUCCESS
WITH URANIUM ONE BACK IN 2009
AND 2010.
ACTING SURPRISED BY THE RUSSIAN
ELECTION MEDDLING, ALL THESE
PEOPLE ON THE MEDIA ART EITHER
FLAT OUT LYING TO YOU OR THEY
ARE JUST TOTALLY IGNORANT.
YOU PICK.
EITHER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WAS NOT COMPARED FOR RUSSIA
TRYING TO INTERFERE IN OUR
ELECTION, OR HIS ADMINISTRATION
MADE A CHOICE TO IGNORE THE
THREAT.
PROBABLY THE LATTER.
PROBABLY BECAUSE I THOUGHT
HILLARY IS GOING TO WIN.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
THAT'S WHY PRESIDENT OBAMA
TONIGHT, IF YOU REALLY CARE
ABOUT THIS, OWES YOU, AT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND
EXPLANATION.
ALSO BREAKING AT THIS HOUR, NOW
THAT ROBERT MUELLER HAS INDICTED
THE 13 RUSSIAN NATIONALS, VERY
SERIOUS LEGAL QUESTIONS ARE
BEING RAISED ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON, ABOUT THE DNC,
ABOUT THE LAW FIRM, ABOUT FUSION
GPS, AND ABOUT THAT FORMER
BRITISH BY CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE FROM THE
WEBSITE LAW AND CRIME.
"DOES MUELLER INDICTMENT MEAN
CLINTON CAMPAIGN CAN BE INDICTED
FOR CHRISTOPHER STEELE?"
WAIT A MINUTE, IS THERE A DOUBLE
STANDARD?
OF THE ARTICLE MAKES SOME
FASCINATING LEGAL POINTS.
ROBERT MUELLER INDICTED THE
NOTION TROLLS IN PART FOR
FAILING TO REGISTER AS FOREIGN
AGENTS OF NOT REPORTING THEIR
ACTIVITIES TO THE ELECTIONS
COMMISSION.
IF THAT'S THE LEGAL STANDARD
THAT MUELLER HAS SET UP, THAT'S
FINE.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL SHOULD ALSO
BE LOOKING TO LOOKING INTO
HILLARY CLINTON, FUSION GPS, AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HERE'S WHY.
HE IS A FOREIGN CITIZEN, A
FORMER BRITISH SPY.
HE WAS PAID BY FUSION GPS
THROUGHOUT LONG FIRM.
THE LAW FIRM TIED TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN IN DNC.
WE SEE NOTHING TO SUGGEST HE WAS
A REGISTERED FOREIGN AGENT AND
REPORTED TO THE SEC THAT HE WAS
BEING COMPENSATED.
IF THAT'S ALL TRUE, GIVEN THE
INFORMATION, THAT WOULD MEAN
THAT FUSION GPS, PERKINS COOLEY,
THE DNC, THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE SHOULD ALL BE
IN SERIOUS LEGAL JEOPARDY.
AT A MINIMUM, MUELLER SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATING THEM, OR IS THERE
A DOUBLE STANDARD?
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A COMPLAINT
FILED AGAINST THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC, ACCUSING
THEM OF VIOLATING CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAWS FOR FAILING TO
DISCLOSE THE UP TO $12 MILLION
THAT WAS SHELLED OUT TOO FOND OF
THE DOSSIER.
WE KNOW THAT THE DOSSIER WAS
USED TO INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT.
USE LIES TO MANIPULATE YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE ALSO KNOWN NOW THAT IT WAS
USED BY THE FBI TO GET THAT FISA
WARRANT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IN AN ELECTION YEAR, AN
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE.
THAT IS THE ONLY EVIDENCE WE
HAVE AFTER OVER A YEAR, GOING ON